ces élèves de 3e ont droit à un cours
d'art plastique un peu particulier
l'exercice du jour définir le design
d'une voiture jeune et futuriste et il
s'applique un thème original dans un
lieu original car pendant 3 jours ces
collégiens de trappe ont classe au
Technocentre Renault des cours dirigés
en binôme par leur professeur habituel
et un salarié de l'entreprise ici on
aborde le design une branche pas
toujours connue par des jeunes de cet
âge il faut pas négliger le le fait que
le le pédagogique à l'école c'est aussi
des cours magistraux mais ça empêche que
ça permet de découvrir des métiers que
les les jeunes dans dans leur quartier
n'ont pas l'habitude de voir donc c'est
une opportunité effectivement pour
l'entreprise de le présenter et encore
une fois travail pour le futur une fois
l'exercice fini les élèves ont voté pour
le meilleur projet et si Chell n'a pas
gagné il a au moins appris quelques
notions sur le métier d'Olivier j'ai pas
découvert des métiers parce que je
connaissais déjà tous les métiers mais
je connais pas on fait quoi dans ces
métiers là en dehors des cours les
élèves découvrent chaque jour des postes
de travail une autre manière de mieux
connaître ce qui se cache derrière des
noms de métier comme vitrier juriste ou
électrochimiste cette passerelle entre
l'école et l'entreprise va aider ces
jeunes à s'orienter mais aussi à leur
montrer que l'enseignement a bien une
application concrète dans le monde du
travail hier ils utilisaient les
mathématiques pour construire un projet
commercial cet après-midi ils aborderont
les expériences à l'in en cours
d'anglais c'est un projet qu'on va
développer c'est-à-dire on va le mener
peut-être différemment avec comme
objectif de le proposer à tout un niveau
d'élèv d'avoir pas une entreprise
partenaire mais 10 au moins 10
c'est-à-dire deux entreprises par classe
donc avec beaucoup plus de souplesse ce
projet est quand même assez lourd à
mener faute de place seul 24 élèves de
3e ont été sélectionné cette année le
dispositif a vu le jour en 2009 pour le
Technocentre Renault il s'agissait d'une
première mais il est déjà prêt à
renouveler l'expérience àis aux
entreprises